joe biden now at 38 approval and even
cnn is covering it how do americans
think president biden is handling the
country and specifically these economic
concerns well you showed his overall job
approval rating a bit earlier here it is
again the 38 approved 62
disapproved this is a numeric low mark
for the president in cnn polling but
he's been in this low range which is a
big warning sign of course for his party
but i would also note republicans and
independents have stayed pretty
consistent one of the reasons his
numbers have gone down a bit jake is
because he's losing support among his
fellow democrats then we asked folks how
about how's he doing on a series of
issues 46 approval on the situation in
ukraine 39 approval on immigration but
take a look at these numbers here
on the economy he's at 30 approval below
his overall approval and on inflation
only 25 percent of respondents approve
of how the president is tackling what is
the most pressing issue by far people
say in terms of the economies impacting
their family
how is biden doing compared to his
predecessors
one way we look at that jake we asked
folks do you believe joe biden has the
right priorities okay so right now only
31 percent say yes president biden has
the right priority 68 percent say no
this is up 10 points uh since we scored
this uh last year in the biden
presidency so now let's take a look at
how that 31 who say yes he has the right
priorities stacks up against his modern
era predecessors look at that not very
well 31 for biden is clearly the low
water mark of all trump obama bush and
clinton on this score jake
that's shocking james do you remember
there was an orange guy i always forget
his name he had crazy hair he was orange
eight mcdonald's um who never hit 38
despite the media always trying to take
him out the media's propped this guy up
and he's at 38 this is this is pretty
extraordinary don't you think
yeah i mean
what's extraordinary is that it's at 38
and not you know like negative 8 or
something um it's absolutely astonishing
to me but at least what we're seeing is
as you said people are waking up in
droves everywhere i go whether i talk to
republicans whether i talk to democrats
people are seeing whether it's with the
grooming of the kids especially the men
the mad moms or the war moms as i like
to call them are getting very upset
people are waking up all over the
country it doesn't matter which issue
people are are now aware that
something's wrong these gas prices and
then then we have both uh biden and
you know mayor lenin i mean pete come
out and say the secret uh
transportation secretary people judge
saying that you know oh i'll suck it up
and get an electric car you know we got
to accelerate the contradictions people
are aware that this is not a government
that's working for americans or for
america and
you know libby mentioned uh kamala
harris i started to laugh because her
name was invoked a moment ago she was
tasked with something that's hilarious
on its own because that's not going to
happen but um
you know
everybody sees this this is just
a clown show that nothing is going to to
happen nothing in this administration is
meant to work for americans and people
are uh i call her vice president red
pills by the way uh people are very
rapidly waking up to the disaster of
this thing and it's the best news ever
um because it's about time that we move
on from this mess
alicia are you worried that the system
always finds a way that despite
all the mad moms despite the polling all
of that stuff that it's like they'll
either bring covet back or they'll
monkey pox us or
they'll make ukraine into a nuclear war
or just like something because everyone
is sort of feeling like wow we're
starting to win polls are showing it but
we're still
three months or you know four months
basically out from an election i i don't
know how in that three or four months
they're going to change the reality for
a lot of men and women in the united
states who are just seeing outrageous
costs not only at the pump but at the
grocery store we were just in michigan
for a week and a half for a family
wedding and i told my husband i was
stunned i went to three different local
grocery stores and i always think wow la
cost of living so high guess what the
only two things that were cheaper in
northern michigan were fuel and michigan
fresh cherries everything else from the
meat to the eggs to dairy everything was
the same price that i pay here in los
angeles that is difficult because the
cost of living in la of course rent and
stuff is more expensive but if you're a
minimum wage worker or a factory worker
or a blue collar or even white-collar
worker in a blue state like michigan who
recent polling numbers have shown biden
is doing abysmally after winning that
state democrats have a big problem and
they can't flip the switch overnight